francis haugen says she never wanted to
be a whistleblower but since leaving
facebook with tens of thousands of
internal documents earlier this year her
alarm call has been heard around the
world october the 5th u.s congress
october 25th the uk parliament a message
that is deeply critical of the way
facebook is run mark zuckerberg
has unilateral control over three
billion people right there's no will at
the top to make sure these systems are
run in an adequately safe way the
systems frances haugen is most concerned
about are the algorithms promoting
content to users of the social media
giant i've seen lots of research that
says that kind of ranking
based ranking prioritizes polarizing
extreme divisive content it doesn't
matter if you're on the left or on the
right it pushes you to the extremes and
it fans hate right anger and hate is the
easiest way to grow on facebook she says
it's a system that's being abused
there's something called virality
hacking where you figure out all the
tricks on how to optimize facebook and
good actors good publishers are already
publishing all the content they can they
can do
but bad actors have an incentive to
play the algorithm facebook executives
know this says francis haugen but the
reason they haven't changed the
algorithm is money they think user
engagement would decline and with it ad
revenues i think there is a view inside
the company that safety is a cost a cost
center it's not a growth center which i
think is very short term in thinking u.s
congress and regulators are
investigating facebook's part in the
deadly storming of the u.s capital an
independent report commissioned by
facebook said it failed to stop the
platform being used to incite ethnic
violence in myanmar so ms halgan
believes there's a real world cost in
lives i have no doubt that the chat like
the events we're seeing around the world
things like myanmar and ethiopia those
are the opening chapters because
engagement based ranking does two things
one it prior prioritizes and amplifies
divisive polarizing extreme content and
two it gets hyper concentrated in you
know five percent of the population
and you only need three percent of the
population on the streets to have a
revolution facebook says much of the
reporting is based on a false premise
yes we're a business and we make profit
they say but the idea that we do so at
the expense of people's safety or
well-being misunderstands where our own
commercial interests lie the truth is
we've invested 13 billion dollars and
have over 40 000 people to do one job
keep people safe on facebook
but with a consortium of news
organizations going over the thousands
of pages of leaked internal memos
facebook's crisis isn't over yet rory
challen's al jazeera